we're talking forza horizon 3 like an
open world racing game that Pete and I
tried out a little bit we did not like a
review it or anything that'll be a
Miguel conception for Christopher
gamespot yes I mean bar go is up me and
bar goes up yeah review is out it got a
9 and a lot of places are giving it a 9
95 see a lot of hundreds out there yeah
uh it's a pretty good canyon oh you're
serious yeah okay cool and I knows a
good game i don't know i was getting
like tens and what not well you know
yeah some sites love to give tens some
sites it is a game that is beautiful
it's very forgiving it's sort of like
arcade type driving like you can pretty
much pick up any car and drive and be
pretty successful you can run into trees
no problem you can hit other cars no
problem the problem I mean you're free
to do whatever you want and it's really
just sort of about exploring the
Australian Pacific coast so there's a
great pretty good variety like I only
played for gosh 45 minutes which was a
great taste like it I really want to
play the game um and I saw like a lot of
good stuff I saw like I said beaches I
went to the forest I was on what looked
like a golf course and I shouldn't have
been I was in like a Lamborghini but I
was doing all this great fun stuff in it
you know remind me I was some of the
time I spent playing to crew back in the
day and that game it sort of had a lot
of the same stuff it allowed you to
drive explore a lot of different
locations to wear this is focused on one
part of a continent the crew was like
all of America there's something about
42 horizon that you just immediately
feels that much more gratifying yeah um
I think it's that the driving is so much
better um and the landscapes are just
crafted in a much more interesting way
yeah imagine that they actually like
focus on the driving in a driving game
and it feels good I was do I ended up
kind of like doing the donuts while I'm
driving and then reversing than going in
the same direction yeah that down pat a
little bit um I saw you when I came back
from I your desk and you were just going
off this rock ramp into the to the beach
just jumped off a cliff into the ocean
clearly ignoring like the events and
objective which is the cool part of this
game like that's why I want to play and
I don't necessarily like racing games or
at least I don't gravitate toward them
and that's why I want I wanted something
I could shut off and maybe just play
every once in a while just for the joy
of driving and seeing this like what is
a gorgeous world with this I like what
southeastern Australian I'm actually not
sure which part I think it's mostly the
Pacific coast I know that's just
southeast but yeah uh yeah it just makes
you the the bear act of driving the
focus and really fun there is sort of
this overarching thing where you're
supposed to be participating in car
festivals just like a music festival and
you are using these festivals as a means
to like build your brand mm-hmm and
perform PR stunts I guess I gotta find
an excuse for a narrative in this game
it doesn't really need one but there are
some questionable characters early on
and like the intro with like these these
bro voices yeah I know you could pick
from like a set number of nicknames I
forgot what my character's name was like
Natasha or something I have no idea but
I wasn't particularly interested in the
people I just in the cars and driving
them yeah but then yeah you can so you
can like create your own events right
and then that's where like the
multiplayer comes into play other people
can participate in them you can make
like challenges and upload them I
believe because you own I haven't had I
haven't played that much unfortunately
but you were not across these avatars
that are just like they take I think
names from your friends list or at least
they just take random people's names and
make them like your drivatar that you
can challenge yeah so just driving on
the road and this is the third year the
driver to our system has been in place
and I think it translates across games
maybe it's just a horizon thing I don't
know if it's a foursome motorsport
proper thing as well but yeah like these
sort of you know they'd there learn
behaviors from the way that other people
have driven and then yeah it's not like
you're driving with that person in this
mode like I was playing offline and i
still had drivatar is on there no it
wasn't offline anyway I'm rambling now
and you're building up a garage the
whole time I was sure it's kind of like
an n 7 car from like mass effect there
at DLC that came along with it or
something yeah that was just there when
i booted it up I mean it's a but you
know I'm driving past all these cars or
it's like that's Nomar too that's a
Jaguar like it makes me want to figure
out how to get those cars and drive them
it is uh I hate that I'd like car
passion I guess that's a thing yeah you
all have it inside of us I think it's
costing something to rip our chests open
and nique it out yeah ports horizon may
do that Miguel are freelance reviewers
saying it's kind of like well these are
my words not his like
it's almost like that call of duty thing
I find myself playing Call of Duty
multiplayer just because of how
constantly I'm unlocking something or
how constantly the experience is
translating into tangible rewards
whether their aesthetic or actually
affecting the mechanics yeah but he was
saying that's pretty constant here it's
like a flurry of just like oh you get
this many followers you just unlock this
car you got this new you actually like
hire artists for the festival venue you
get points for driving like an [ __ ]
yeah you could like near-misses know
like a collisions damage pulling like
you deserve anything you do basically
you're gonna earn points which you know
there's something to be do some question
they're like okay is it actually make it
a valuable experience when you add it on
top of the the great driving yeah why
not it is just sort of that extra layer
that makes it a little bit more enticing
did you get the chance to go much like
off-road on the beaches and like yeah
actually in a Lamborghini I was gonna
say yeah like when you were supposed to
be off road no buggy as opposed to a
Beemer no I know I'm that's what I'm
looking forward to do this weekend
honestly Miguel sold the game so well
and just even playing it just a little
bit made me realize like yeah this is
going to be a great experience and I
stick with it well see ya in terms of
negatives there's just me I was saying
like minor performance issues online
which i guess like yeah every games
gonna suffer that clearly wasn't enough
to like hinder his experience and then
he didn't like the brand narrative
either I don't blame them in that kind
of social media the Millennial
Generation III can't stand Millennials
they're the worst like hell yeah gemelli
I know I are you guys are too aren't you
I don't know borderline anyway forza
horizon 3 got an eye on gamespot so
check out that review by miguel
conception on our website